l'île de france en 2030 ce sera plus de
60 nouvelles gares 240 km de métro en
plus 70 km de rer prolongée et autant
pour le tramway améliorer encore les
transports en commun en ile de france ce
sera l'un des objectifs de jean paul
huchon le président de la région vous
allez avoir des prolongations de lignes
de métro et de tramway qui vont
évidemment rapprocher les franciliens de
leur travail ou de leur logement et puis
vous allez avoir autour des gares
véritablement une urbanisation qui fait
que globalement aucun habitant ne sera
plus de deux minutes d'une gare cette
promesse d'améliorer encore la mobilité
c'est celle du nouveau schéma directeur
de la région ile de france
ce document dessine le visage de l'île
de france d'ici à 2030
à cette date la région comptera
davantage de logements 70 milles seront
construits tous les ans avec 30% de hlm
est une ambition construire autour des
gares pour lutter contre l'étalement
urbain et le gaspillage foncier on a
donc choisi en effet d'être plutôt sur
une ville intense sirkis est pas la
densité pour l'intensité qui nous
intéresse c'est la densité de qualité
c'est à dire que le francilien de 2,80
puisse retrouver tout ce dont il a
besoin les espaces de respiration le
commerce les écoles il faudrait pas
qu'on construise et qu'on s'aperçoive
qu'on n'a pas le bon niveau d'équipement
par exemple je crois que ça doit se
faire dans un double rapport rapport
bien sûr région collectivité de ces
collectivités et les franciliens ce
qu'ils ont à vivre au local cette
intensité
la majorité régionale entend aussi
encourager la création d'emplois
jean paul huchon table sur une
croissance de 2,5 pour cent pour espérer
créer 28 mille emplois franciliens
supplémentaires chaque année